Speaker 1: This is absolutely tremendous.
Donald Trump is fully turning on evangelicals
for his 2024 run as the race seems to be
collapsing for Trump. We never count him
out. We know what happened in 2016, but
Trump is in trouble here. Early trouble,
and evangelicals seem to be abandoning him,
and he is now furious with the evangelicals.
This is part of that interview we looked
at earlier where he appeared on the water
cooler with David Brody appearing by phone.
Trump's new thing, He's on by by phone,
not by video. And here he is talking about
the disloyalty of evangelical leaders who
have the audacity not to endorse Trump.
Speaker 2: You are the ultimate fighter,
the ultimate counterpuncher, for sure. And that
makes me think of evangelicals, why they loved
you twice in those elections. And you announce
when you announce your candidacy, at least as it
stands now, some of these prominent evangelical
leaders who backed you last time, they're not
yet willing to commit like Robert Jeffress is,
not some others. It seems like many of them are
waiting to see how the field takes shape before
backing anyone. What is your message to them?
Speaker 3: Well, I don't really care at all.
Speaker 1: Oh, my goodness. Antifa
has gotten into Trump's audio.
Speaker 3: As a sign of disloyalty. There's great
disloyalty in the world to politics, and that
decided disloyalty because nobody, as you know,
and you would know better than anybody because
you do such a great job, nobody has ever done
more for right to life than Donald Trump. I put
three Supreme Court justices who all voted and
they got something that they've been fighting
for for 64 years or many, many years, and nobody
thought they could win it. You know, they they
won Roe v Wade. They won. They finally won. And,
you know, I got a little disappointed because
I thought they could have fought much harder
during the election, during the 22 election,
because, you know, they won and a lot of them
didn't fight or weren't really around to
fight. And it did energize the Democrats.
Speaker 1: So it's a sign of disloyalty, says
Trump, that these evangelical leaders won't come
out and support him. Now, here's the reality.
It never made sense for evangelical Republicans
to support Donald Trump. It never made sense. And
so now use whatever phrase you like. The chickens
are coming home to roost. What goes around comes
around. The bill is come do whatever. This was
a sort of forced the impact all along for the
evangelicals. They really didn't like Hillary.
They sort of wanted Ted Cruz. And then that
didn't work out. And Trump called Ted Cruz's wife
ugly and things didn't go well. And ultimately
they had Trump or Hillary as their choice.
And then it was Trump or Biden and Biden's
Catholic. And a lot of evangelicals don't
like that either. And so they went with Trump
overwhelmingly, but it never made sense. Look
at Trump's past behavior. Look at Trump's
past statements, the extramarital affairs,
the profanity, the, you know, way that he has
talked about women in the past. It doesn't align
with what the evangelicals want us to believe.
Other Christian values now want us to believe is
doing some heavy lifting there, because are these
really their values? That's kind of a different
question. Trump's policy, by the way, Trump's
policies on health care and immigration aren't
really very Christian either. Based on what
are more. More enlightened understandings of
what those Christian views are. And at the end
of the day, the evangelicals now are saying to
themselves, we might not have to go with Trump.
Let's not jump on the Trump train early, because
maybe somebody else will actually best Trump
in the Republican primary. So the evangelicals
seemingly turning on Trump, Trump immediately
turning on the evangelicals, because remember,
anyone who doesn't immediately, wholeheartedly
and unanimously support Trump is being disloyal.
A couple weeks ago, it was the Jews being disloyal
to Trump. Now it's the evangelicals. That's the
framing. That's the that's the black white
thinking that people like Trump narcissist,
egomaniacs. That is the framing through which
they interpret others actions. We're going to
take a very quick break. Make sure you subscribe
to the YouTube channel at YouTube.com slash The
David Pakman Show. What a program we have for you
today. One of our sponsors is Curiositystream the
best place to find and watch documentaries on
politics, history, science, technology, nature,
you name it, they have it. Curiositystream has
a deeper collection of documentaries than any
other streaming service. They add new titles
every week, including exclusive award winning
films and shows you can't watch anywhere
else. I just watched ancient engineering
fascinating insights into how stuff was built
before modern technology and the Industrial
Revolution. You can watch Curiositystream on all
of your devices. Phone, desktop Game console,
Smart TV. I'm always finding great documentaries
on Curiositystream that I can't find on any other
platforms. It's really the only place to go for
documentaries and they have a great deal for my
audience. You can get Curiositystream for an
entire year for 15 bucks. That's a dollar 25 a
month. Go to curiositystream dot com slash Pacman
and use the code Pacman. The link is down below.